hey guys my name is Pierre Peru
welcome to five weird stuff online
[Music]
oh boy oh boy we have a great show today
pros but before we begin brothers I need
to get changed
[Laughter]
do I look hot now get it first item is
inflatable [ __ ] fighting the hilarious
dueling game where your weapon it's a
giant [ __ ] Wow and getting excited to
try this out oh yeah I love cons there's
one separate for the bowl sets the
screen banks blowing up [ __ ] is hard
[Music]
round one alright so the challenge might
see in this penis duel the penis comes
off that means you lose you can't use
your hands
and it's best out of three you ready yes
one two three despite strong penis I
practice every day to become the
greatest run to this penis final round
penis fight game
[Music]
all right beautiful next item Bros is
liquid ass I don't know if it's a pepper
spray oh my god I thought it was a
pepper spray I could have sprayed that
in my mouth all right for us the next
item is did you yes I set the sponsor
eagle what what oh my god it's the next
month in loot crate the new theme that's
coming up next month is fantasy but this
one should be spy-related let's open it
up
also be sure to tweet me and hashtag
loot parrots with you opening your loot
box late so duteous alright first off a
t-shirt that says this is stirred very
classy very meat well feel notes
classified okay
stealth wristwatch all right I'll try it
out oh cool all right that's cool I
thought it was just a joke that it
didn't tell time but you see it's black
now but I click gate and it shows the
time
that's pretty awesome next up we have a
game called mad libs world's greatest
word game a super silly way to fill in
the plural all right let's try this okay
you're supposed to play this with
someone well I don't have any friends so
I'll save that one for maybe one one day
[Music]
whoo
a free digital code for ninja ninja AK
which looks like an awesome comic book I
just showed you my code son of a [ __ ]
we got a bracelet now if you click it
something will happen
wow that's cool oh it says here in this
package you will find a paracord
survival bracelet it's made out of
military-grade parachute cord and could
actually save your life okay so the
fabric inside it can be used for a bunch
of stuff that's that's pretty cool so
it's like a survival bracelet all right
I get it I get it
Oh comic book of orphan black Hey
childbirth that's good and inside we
have their computer awesome
alright first so if you want to open
these with me during the show check out
loot crate calm slash boots and tweet me
at hashtag loot pills with your hashtag
load pills and it'll be an amazing fun
time I really enjoyed this package I
think the watch is pretty cool I look
forward to not say the time to anyone
but myself so next theme is going to be
fantasy which I'm excited about because
I'm a huge fantasy fan so they switch a
theme every month the 19th so if you
want the fantasy theme you have to order
before the 19th all right let's move on
to the next item
[Music]
so inflatable instant poop job
affordable removable immediate results
no painful surgery the secret to a fab
cleavage well I'm all about that fab
let's try it out oh I like our last
episode literally last episode we did a
boob enhancer by the end of this show
I'll just be a plastic surgeon alright
so here's the boobs if they're not the
same size don't worry ladies that is
normal nothing to be ashamed of I felt
pretty good okay you want to play with
my tits you wanna play with my titties
[Music]
the aisle I always save the best for
last
so this is pretty amazing
I gotta say it's nothing it says nothing
for the person who has everything
congratulations you have received the
gift of nothing absolutely nothing this
is the ultimate and minimalism less is
more and more as ice okay five dollars
for this
[Music]
anyway that's all for now thank you both
so much for watching I'll see in the
next one as always stay awesome bros
remember to check out loot crate comm
slash pills and enter the code payloads
and you will get 10% off don't miss out
on that offer
I'll see you bros in the next one